d'abord le texte sur le pass sanitaire
adopté hier soir et les modifications
attendues au sénat avec sauvage
seulement une voix d'écart après de vifs
débats les députés ont voté pour la
possibilité de recourir au pass annie
terre jusqu'au 31 juillet si la
situation l'exigé c'est le troisième
projet de loi abordant la question du
passant cinq mois le gouvernement
justifie cette mesure par l'évolution de
l'épidémie il ya une reprise de
l'épidémie constate à peu près partout
en europe cette situation cette reprise
qui est probablement liée en grande
partie aux conditions hivernales et au
fait que le virus circule davantage dans
ces conditions nous savons
malheureusement désormais présentée
comme une boîte à outils le projet de
loi de vigilance sanitaire offre une
batterie de mesures pour freiner
l'épidémie les députés ont adopté
l'amendement du gouvernement qui
permettent aux chefs d'établissements
scolaires de connaître le statut
vaccinal de leurs élèves une mesure
visant à faciliter l'organisation de
campagnes de dépistage et de vaccination
au sein des collèges et des lycées
certains dénoncent une entorse au
principe du secret médical
ça ne paraît pas être
le rôle d'un chai talisman que de
commencer à contrôler la situation
sanitaire des des enfants
sur les onze vaccins obligatoires
là on peut parce que pour entrer à
l'école il faut être vaccinés avec ses
onze vaccin obligatoire depuis
maintenant quelques années sur cette
opération je suis très très réservé et
donc ça viendra au sénat pour le chef de
file des socialistes au sénat la
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 doit
devenir obligatoire le projet de loi
sera examiné à la chambre haute le 28
octobre où ni la majorité de droite ni
les élus de gauche ne cachent leurs
réticences et on débat autour de cette
prolongation du pass sanitaire avec mes
invités sandra notamment soir bienvenue
vous êtes député à l'om de l'isère
stéphane le rudulier bonsoir sénateurs
et l'air du rhône paul cassia bonsoir à
vous professeur de droit public et
constitutionnel à paris 1 panthéon
sorbonne avec nous en visioconférence
l'épidémiologiste philippe amouyel
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi et
lætitia cru pas éditorialiste à mes
côtés comme tous les mardis et tous les
jeudis dans ce sens public donc
prolongation jusqu'au 31 juillet vous
l'avez vu passé d'extrême justesse à
l'assemblée examiné au sénat ce sera
vendredi prochain 28 octobre sandra
motards heureusement que vous étiez là
hier soir et que vous avez voté parce
que sinon ça passait pas série crack
pourquoi pourquoi sont ils selon vous
prolonger ce pass sanitaires alors
d'abord je tiens à dire que pendant que
le texte était voté dans la en séance on
est en train de travailler aussi en
commission notamment sur le budget donc
on était au moins deux commissions à
travailler en même temps sur le budget
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya quelques
voix des deux camps mais on était quand
même là eh oui il n'y avait pas de
risque majeur donc on a continué notre
travail pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
donner la possibilité en fait au
gouvernement de pouvoir requérir s'il a
besoin à 7
finalement cet état d'urgence amis là
bas parce qu'on ne sait pas où on va
encore on voit en ce moment en grande
bretagne on a une recrudescence avec un
sou variant du delta on n'est pas à
l'abri encore hélas on aimerait alors
c'est vrai que les français sont
massivement vacciner ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle parce que ça nous
protège on sait que le vaccin ça protège
des formes graves et que ça empêche les
contagions donc 1 78% des voix se
donnant encore et encore une vraie marge
de progression notamment sur les très
jeunes les 12-18 et sur les personnes
âgées fragiles donc il faut encore qu'on
aille les chercher donc c'est important
de pouvoir se donner les moyens de
réagir s'il ya besoin s'il ya vraiment
matière à le faire et pourquoi jusqu'en
juillet on va moi je vais être très
clair tout de suite parce
qu'effectivement à partir du mois de
février ben on arrête on arrête nos
travaux à l'assemblée au sénat pour être
dans une période on y est déjà dans une
période un peu particulière pour
l'instant on est en précampagne on voit
déjà que la moindre décision qu'on prend
pour plus de six mois nous provoquent
des commentaires sur le fait qu' on
utilise notre mandat pour la campagne je
vous laisse imaginer ce que ça pourrait
donner en pleine campagne de devoir
effectivement faire ce type de deux
sessions extraordinaires et les débats à
n'en plus finir que ça aurait alors même
qu'on serait dans une urgence c'est
l'air alors on a entendu vos différents
arguments et je pense que nos invités
pourront il répond stéphane rudulier
peut-être déjà un point de principe dans
huit jours voter pour voter contre alors
de toute façon on aménagera le sénat a
tout le temps était sage sur ce sujet
étant donné qu'on ne sait pas jamais
opposé au mois de juillet notamment vos
pass sanitaires si ce n'est un point
nous sommes dans un régime d'exception
on est dans un régime d'urgence
sanitaire il ya une restriction des
libertés individuelles
incontestablement la question est de
savoir si on prolonge ce régime
déception jusqu'en juillet ou si
incontestablement on a besoin d'une
clause de revoyure en février ou mars là
où juste avant la clôture des travaux là
où je vous rejoins moins c'est que la
constitution ne nous interdit pas de
nous réunir en mars ou en avril ça s'est
déjà fait en 2007 rien ne l'interdît
donc car je pense que dans la même
logique que au mois de juillet nous
allons
restreindre la durée
d'habilitation afin qu'on puisse évaluer
la situation épidémique en février ou
mars pour prendre des bonnes décisions
mais sur le bilan actuel vous avez dit
une chose qui est très importante
effectivement il compte il n'ya campagne
de vaccination massive et c'était tout
l'objet du pass sanitaires ça c'était un
pari réussi puisque ça a été dans les
discussions aujourd'hui
philosophiquement la question se pose
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à
restreindre les libertés individuelles
pour 10 à 15% des personnes qui ne sont
pas rentrées dans le schéma vaccinal
tiers concerné 2 entre guillemets
d'embêter les 80 % qui ont joué le jeu
pour absolument ça c'est vraiment une
question philosophique et voire même par
rapport au conseil constitutionnel
puisque au moins d'août effectivement il
a trouvé proportionnée les mesures
législatives
je ne sais pas s'il aura la même
position au mois de novembre contre la
loi arrivera dans quelle mesure le pass
and iter est une contrainte pour une
personne vaccinée qui de toute façon a
de fait se passe mais une contrainte
quand même pour ces raisons c'est un
mythe mais ce que vous venez
de le montrer de devoir montrer quelque
chose parce que devoir montrer quelque
chose dans des lieux publics c'est quand
même une contrainte indéniable enfin
j'ai cessé lui ni contrainte c'est à
dire montrer son téléphone ou son papier
on a quand même en france et circulent
allawi circuit leinster qui va ya eu des
débats sur la conservation des données
vous le savez très bien mais plus que
vigilants quant à restaurateurs par
exemple vérifie c'est 30 minutes s'est
gardé 30 minutes sur le terminal
fabriqué il a vérifié si j'entends bien
j'entends bien mais quand même on est
dans un pays de liberté on peut libre
alors je me suis rendu là je vais donner
la parole à paul cassia dans un instant
mais je voudrais entendre philippe
amouyel peut-être sur le le justificatif
épidémiologique quand le gouvernement et
évoque l'éventualité d'un rebond
épidémique il est réel qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire là-dessus
oui bien sûr sur le pass sanitaires on
va prendre deux exemples les anglais
tout d'abord qui sont en train de faire
face à une nouvelle vague épidémique
mais pas une vague de crises sanitaires
1 ils ont qu'ils sont quand même vacciné
essentiellement parce que depuis le 15
juillet ils ont abandonné toute mesure
varinard ciblés dans le métronome il ya
deux personnes sur dix qui portent des
masques premier point deuxième fois le
danemark à l'autre extrême ils ont mis
le pass and i ter en place très tôt au
mois de mars ils l'ont enlevée ya quinze
jours la courbe est en train de remonter
ça veut dire que certes on arrive à
compte l'épidémie à cause de la
vaccination dupas sanitaires et des
mesures variées donc il faut qu'on
continue à contrôler l'épidémie jusqu'à
ce qu'on soit bien sûr que enfin on
arrive dans une phase qu'on appelle
endémique sert le virus est là mais ne
s'étend plus et les estimations moi j'ai
fait de même au début de l'épidémie
c'est que l'an des mines apparaîtra
probablement qu'au printemps ou à l'été
prochain donc il ya du sens
épidémiologique à maintenir la
possibilité de continuer à utiliser ce
pas sanitaire
cancan deux interlocuteurs disait 85%
pour 15% de la population le problème
c'est que ces 15% de la population font
quand même courir un risque sanitaire il
suffit de 5 millions personnes non
vaccinées pour déclencher les formes
graves en particulier il n'en reste
incertain ne sont pas vaccinés est
saturé l'hôpital et c'est ça qui
déclenche les problèmes je vous redonne
la parole évidemment tout à l'heure vous
vous vous diriez quoi paul cassia cas
exceptionnel se banalise en quelques
secondes d'abord je dirais que une
société du risque zéro n'existe pas il
sur le plan sécuritaire et sur le plan
sanitaire non plus si on attend que le
virus du convive 19 serait soit
éradiquée je crois qu'il faut tout de
suite partir sur l'idée que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire ce ne sera pas
exceptionnelle mais définitif doit être
ancrée dans nos habitudes ça c'est le
premier point il faut accepter un
minimum de risque et le taux de
vaccination qui n'est pas de 78% comme
vous l'avez dit mais qui est de presque
90 % de la population éligible et déjà
considérables et à ce pourcentage il
faut ajouter celui des personnes qui ont
été contaminées par l'aco idée qui
bénéficie pour ce faire d'une immunité
naturelle dont je fais partie par
conséquent comme l'a dit le sénateur il
ya un instant le pass annie terre a
atteint son objectif qui était de
contraindre à la vaccination et on ne
peut pas sur la base d'éléments putatif
qui consiste à dire que peut-être qu'à
l'été 2022
l'épidémie va reprendre on ne peut pas
continuer à conserver un régime qui
lorsqu'il a été institué en mars 2001
c'est à dire il ya presque deux ans a
été présentée comme exceptionnelle
il ne faut jamais s'habituer à banaliser
l'exceptionnalité il faut toujours
considérer que le régime qui consiste à
nous confiner
prévoir des couvre-feux prévoir des spas
sanitaires c'est pas du tout anodin de
présenter son qr codes à l'entrée d'un
cinéma d'un restaurant d'un café ou à
l'entrée du sénat c'est très contents
pour moi c'est très contraignant et sa
appel si vous voulez par la suite
d'autres mesures de contrainte qu'on ne
peut pas prévoir donc il faut absolument
supprimer pour la raison qu'a dit le
sénateur c'est qu'en france on est dans
un pays de liberté le principe c'est la
liberté la restriction c'est l'exception
alors on va continuer dans des bas je
voudrais que alexandre pouces arnaud
nous rejoignent pour le bon soir eq
centre pour regarder en détail le
dispositif le dispositif actuel est ce
qui permet au gouvernement de faire oui
alors ça fait un an et demi
effectivement qu'on vit sous divers
régime juridique d'exception
alors d'abord l'état d'urgence sanitaire
avec ce projet de loi le gouvernement
souhaite et bien projet cet état
d'urgence sanitaire mais uniquement en
guyane capitulation épidémique est
inquiétante et est bien avec cet état
d'urgence sanitaire le gouvernement
pourra éventuellement confiné toute la
guyane il en aura le pouvoir jusqu'au 31
décembre
2021 mais pour l'instant seulement un
couvre-feu est instauré entre 20h et 5h
du matin ensuite sur l'ensemble du
territoire national le gouvernement
souhaite un projet ce qu'on appelle et
bien un régime de sortie de crise
sanitaire ou plutôt ce que le
gouvernement appelle un régime de sortie
de crise mais en réalité et bien c'est
un état d'urgence sanitaire allégé qui
lui donne quand même des pouvoirs
d'exception alors outre le plan
sanitaire le gouvernement pourrait et
bien décidé d'un confinement ou d'un
couvre-feu mais uniquement au niveau
local sur les territoires où le virus
circule activement il pourrait aussi
fermé des restaurants des commerces et
interdire à des rassemblements alors ces
pouvoirs d'exception le gouvernement
souhaite les à voir jusqu'au 31 juillet
2022 pendant huit mois et ça le sénat
trouve que c'est vraiment trop long
compte tenu du caractère exceptionnel de
ses pouvoirs écoutez le sénateur
républicain fils bas c'est un argument
d'ordre général la question de savoir
comment le traduit en tous les cas
jamais le sénat qui est cohérent avec
lui-même ou non du parlement n'a accepté
de donner des pouvoirs exceptionnels au
gouvernement pendant une période de 8
mois ça on ne le fait pas tout
simplement parce que quand on restera
nos libertés même si c'est pour un beau
tiff on ne doit pas pouvoir le faire
sans contrôle du parlement pendant une
trop longue période
alors il n'y a pas que le sénat qui est
sceptique sur cet état d'urgence
sanitaire il ya aussi le conseil d'état
l'une des plus haute juridiction
administrative du pays est au début du
mois le conseil d'état a publié un
rapport pour renforcer le contrôle de
ses mesures d'urgence qui sont est bien
utilisé par le gouvernement d'abord
renforcer le contrôle du parlement et
puis encadrer cet état d'urgence dans
notre constitution car eh bien pour le
moment à l'état d'urgence est régi par
la loi donc on peut la changer beaucoup
plus facilement et le conseil d'état
propose également qu'à chaque fois que
le gouvernement a décidé d'instaurer
l'état d'urgence est bien le conseil
constitutionnel soit saisi pour dire si
oui ou non il est pertinent de
restreindre les libertés des français
merci avec sandra tout à l'heure dans
notre dans notre second débat je jouais
qu'on évoque cette question du conseil
constitutionnel paul cassia ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu' il faudra saisir
on peut imaginer une saisie ou des
saisies du conseil constitutionnel dans
les dents les jours dans les mois qui
viennent alors le conseil considère peut
être saisi de deux manières soit au
moment où la loi est adoptée par le
parlement et les parlementaires ou le
premier ministre président de république
le président du sénat l'assemblée
nationale peuvent saisir le pont
séquentiel avant que la loi entre en
vigueur si la loi n'a pas été contrôlé à
ce moment là elle peut l'être a
posteriori c'est à dire au moment où
elle est appliquée par le biais des
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité
ce que propose le conseil d'état c'est
d'assurer une saisine automatique du
conseil constitutionnel dès lors que le
parlement vote une loi sur un état
d'urgence le conseil constitutionnel
serait saisie clown c'est une une
modification peut-être est-ce que c'est
une garantie je ne sais pas parce que le
conseil constitutionnel en la matière on
l'a vu en 2010 est jusqu'à aujourd'hui
exercent un contrôle très abstrait de la
constitutionnalité de la loi pour la
raison simple et juste qui est que le
conseil cossu elle n'a pas un pouvoir
politique égal à celui du parlement et
donc par conséquent ils contrôlent ce
qu'on appelle l' erreur manifeste
d'appréciation et éventuellement commise
par le parlement c'est à dire voilà une
décision qui serait tout à fédérer
nabeul de recourir un état d'urgence et
non pas une situation épidémique très
précise et puis rapidement sur sur la
durée parce qu'on va revenir sur cette
notion pourquoi jusqu'en juillet vous
avez l'un et l'autre donnez vous vos
arguments mais est-ce que selon vous
parce qu'évidemment on enjambe
l'élection présidentielle on ne sait pas
qui sera le prochain président de la
république et ce quel sera son rapport
aux libertés publiques est ce que c'est
un risque pour nous c'est un risque tout
à fait considérable effectivement de
donner la possibilité pour l'exécutif
qui sera désigné en mai 2022 de pouvoir
déclencher l'état d'urgence à sa
convenance je dis bien sa contenance et
je parle sous le contrôle de
l'épidémiologiste qui nous suit de
manière des méthodes dématérialisée
puisque aujourd'hui si la situation
épidémiologique est globalement
satisfaisante si j'en crois ce que ce
qui est dit à peu près partout permet le
maintien d'un sorte d'état d'urgence bis
eh bien pourquoi en irait-il
différemment en mai 2022 pourquoi ne
serait-il impossible de recouvrir des
couvre feux et compris partiel ou à des
confinement à situation à peu près
comparable donc nous sommes en train de
créer notre propre destruction alors
démocratique en procédant de la sorte
argument fort sandra matin qu'est ce que
vous répondez que heureusement on a une
constitution qui nous protège d'un
cinquième enfin la constitution de la
vème république nous protège de quelque
part d'une folie ou d'une envie
hégémonique de quelques présidents que
ce soit qu'ils soient élus donc oui il
faut il faut avoir confiance dans notre
constitution et dans le fait qu'elle
nous protégera de d'un abus finalement
de ce régime là et donc moi je n'en
craint pas comment si effectivement
alors président l'a vu emmanuel macron
décide seul avec trois personnes autour
de lui ça on l'a dit ce qu'ils se
sentent absolument commet une bourde 2
alors c'est absolument faux et
concrètement il ya moins trois raisons
pour ça la première c'est qu'on en est
au 11e texte sur sur cette urgence
sanitaire et que à chaque fois il est
passé au conseil constitutionnel et qu'à
chaque fois même député on a modifié des
choses le dernier texte par exemple on a
raccourci justement le détour on était
d'accord aussi 31 décembre oui mais on
est d'accord ça l'avait on l'avait porté
aussi dans 15 novembre au niveau du cem
on l'a fait on a trouvé un accord et
effectivement avec quotidien pour pour
diminuer ce temps là on alla au
parlement fin à l'assemblée on a mis
aussi des conditions dire qu'on ne peut
pas déclencher les choses j'ai faim les
l'état d'urgence et certaines mesures
sans réunir au moins quatre conditions
qui sont des conditions scientifiques
sur le taux de reproduction sur le taux
d'incidence des choses très clair qui
participent déjà aujourd'hui en fait aux
décisions du gouvernement et avec le
président de la république effectivement
il ne décide pas seul il décide sur des
bases aussi scientifique et concrètement
je crois qu'il faut si la sur lesquels
il décide on les a jamais vraiment eu de
en totalité c'est tout le poids la
problématique de cette gouverneur des la
crise elle cherche excusez moi n'y avait
pas de transparence sur les arguments et
les preuves dont dispose et le chef de
l'état pour décréter ces mesures
d'urgence je vous invite à reprendre à
chaque fois les explications extrêmement
claire d'olivier ferrand sur le pourquoi
on faisait des choses et sur le pourquoi
ont déclenché le comment je vais prendre
un exemple ça a été témoin j'ai été
confronté chez moi sur ma
circonscription à la fermeture d'un
centre commercial de plus de 20 mille
mètres carrés parce qu'on avait un taux
d'incidence qui était supérieure à 200
très clairement on avait une limite il y
avait un décret c'est très clair
l'application sur le territoire elle
s'est faite via les préfets et il n'y a
pas eu à discuter donc là on sait que
quand on atteint effectivement une
certaine limite quand on atteint
certains seuils eh ben on peut
déclencher si on ne les attend pas on ne
déclenche pas d'un des gardes ou c'est
intéressant parce que ça revient
l'un des débats qui a été récurrent sur
la primauté du politique sur le
scientifique dans la gestion de ces
crises est vrai qu'au début de la crise
on a reproché au gouvernement de s'être
finalement totalement dans la main du
comité du conseil scientifique et de ne
pas faire de politique ces fameux
régulier il ya ça s'est inversée après
quand même oui évidemment le 10 juillet
quand le président de la république fait
son discours et on a vu la bascule en
termes de rapidité et celui intégration
de la vaccine mais le rôle du parlement
dans cette affaire c'est de garantir la
pérennité de l'étape droit et en même
temps protéger la santé des français et
c'est tout l'équilibré qu'il faut
rechercher et je pense sincèrement que
demander l'autorisation d'être dans un
régime d'exception sur sept à huit mois
et vous trop important de deux choses
l'une soit à la sortie de l'hiver et
j'entends bien la saisonnalité du virus
à la sortie d'hiver on constate qu'à une
extinction d'épidémie parce qu'on a un
taux de vaccination
importante parce qu'on atteint une sorte
d'immunité collective et à ce moment là
on pourra se poser la question est ce
qu'on sort de cet état d'urgence régime
dérogatoire ou alors on s'aperçoit qu'on
n'arrive pas à juguler cette épidémie et
qu'il faudra maintenir des mesures mais
je pense que le parlement son rôle par
rapport à l'exécutif vous savez que on
assiste quand même un affaiblissement du
parlement l'idée en tant que tel ici
c'est à dire d'un prenons nos
responsabilités
rendez vous mi février mi mars pour
qu'on puisse juger de nous mêmes au
niveau de l'assemblée nationale au
niveau du sénat si oui ou non on doit
sortir de cet état d'urgence et de ce
régime d'exception alors on va avancer
dans ce débat et on va parler de la
question de la troisième dose
de vaccination d'abord laetitia faut un
petit retour en arrière un petit coup
d'oeil dans le rétroviseur il ya
certains politiques et non des moindres
ont fait preuve d'hésitation pour ne pas
dire d'hypocrisie sur l'appel à la
vaccination olivier ferrand a carrément
dit que c'était de la lâcheté 1
concernant christiane taubira c'est
celle qui a fait finalement créé le plus
de polémiques c'était il ya trois
semaines environ sur rtl elle déclare
que comme elle n'est pas en exercice
elle n'est pas politique en exercice
elle n'a pas à appeler les français et
notamment les français de guyane à aller
se faire vacciner
voilà et donc à partir de là il ya un
tollé évidemment ils verront reprend la
main parce qu'on ne peut pas laisser
dire ça quand on est à l'exécutif et
donc ils déplorent il se dit effaré et
déplore donc une forme de lâcheté mais
christiane taubira c'était tout ça par
médias interposés évidemment elle
revient sur france 5 et elle enfonce le
clou en disant non je n'ai je ne suis
pas responsable de cette situation et il
faut une médiatrice est en fait c'est
intéressant dans le discours de
christiane taubira elle met au même plan
les protestataires qu'elle fustige
notamment en disant que c'est un morceau
damacy lité les antilles passe etc les
anti vaccins mais elle met au même plan
les la parole publique voilà en dix ans
les hauts fonctionnaires à la haute
fonction publique et les protestataires
doivent s'entendre et donc autant là
comme l'autre sont dans leur tort c'est
difficile quand on est femme politique
même si on est plus en exercice d'avoir
cette position effectivement
quasi neutre et qu'il ne l'est pas
forcément parce qu'en mettant même plan
et en horizontal is an les laits des
paroles sacrées saxe a sacré la défiance
encore une fois dans la parole publique
un autre exemple qui est vraiment qui
est différent dans dans les dents les
ressorts on va dire c'est jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon c'est
différent pourquoi parce qu'il est
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
donc lui il a bien compris que ces
protestataires qui tous les samedis
manifestent contre le pass sanitaires il
peut potentiellement les récupérer donc
ça s'appelle du clientélisme et donc
dans ses prises de position ils
appellent clairement les antilles passer
les manifestants à venir le rejoindre il
ne se maintenant il ne va plus sur le
terrain vous rappeler que quand il avait
tenté de rallier les gilet jaune ça
avait été un accueil abominable donc ils
ne se risquent plus mais il appelle les
troupes à le rejoindre tout en se
faisant vacciner
donc c'est à dire que lui comme
christiane taubira a c'est un double
discours je me fais vacciner je ne suis
pas contre le vaccin mais je suis contre
le pass sanitaire c'est on comprend
quand on analyse vraiment voilà
l'expression comprends ce qu'ils veulent
dire mais c'est quand même compliqué
comme message et jean luc mélenchon va
encore plus loin parce qu'ils demandent
aux troupes des antilles passe de venir
mais sans les extrêmes droites sans les
militants de l'extrême droite alors
comment trier dans une foule qui est
contre le pass sanitaires on se rend
compte que finalement ces foules créé la
jonction des pôles c'est à dire
qu'effectivement les militants d'extrême
gauche et des militants d'extrême droite
se retrouve derrière un même combat
c'est de l'ordre de la responsabilité
d'un
d'un leader politique ce dont on parle
là bon on va pas revenir parce que ça ça
date un peu mais sur sur la prise de
position de madame taubira
120 matin ça vous a choqué
j'imagine quand vous avez réagi moi de
toute façon tout responsable politique
qui a eu des responsabilités ou qui
aspirent en avoir des plus grandes qui
ne met pas au coeur de son discours la
protection de la santé des français ça
me choque concrètement est clairement
monsieur mélenchon il n'est pas tout
seul effectivement sur son credo on a vu
florian philippot je vais pleurer lio il
est presque mais ils ont tout laissé
dans le politiquement glissons il a
repris je peux vous assurer que sur les
territoires il a repris du poil de la
bête avec ces manifestations anti passe
moi je le vois tout d'un coup chez moi
fleurir donc concrètement
il y à il ya là une sorte
d'irresponsabilité parce que je crois
que quand on fait de la politique notre
objectif c'est le bien commun c'est
l'intérêt général alors on prend des
décisions en ce moments qui sont
difficiles à tous et on aimerait bien ne
pas avoir à les prendre et ne pas vivre
cette crise sanitaire simplement on les
prend en responsabilité en faisant ce
qui nous semble être le mieux pour
protéger les gens allaient dire qu' il
ne faut pas se protéger c'est
extrêmement bon je pense que vous êtes
vous voudriez même jour et qu'on avance
parce qu'il ya cette question de la
troisième dose et puis ensuite il ya un
autre thème qui est vraiment patience et
le secret médical dans les dans les
écoles dans les dans les collèges alors
la troisième dose je vais redonner le
chiffre qu'on sur le taux de vaccination
j'ai cherché je communiquais avec la
rédactrice en chef à l'instant pour
comprendre qu'on n'était pas d'accord le
chiffre de 76 % des personnes éligibles
c'est à partir de 12 ans et le chiffre
que vous donner 90% c'est au delà de 18
ans donc la différence elle est là voilà
on l'a vérifié entre temps on a pris les
minutes nécessaires pour le faire donc
voilà pourquoi on n'était pas tout à
fait d'accord je vais me tourner vers
philippe amouyel su pour savoir sur le
tout la troisième dose on parle de qui
quelle part de la population doit passer
par cette troisième dose de vaccin alors
aujourd'hui c'est clairement avec les
recommandations de la has et plus de 65
ans plus sous les jeunes qui sont
fragiles qui peuvent avoir des déficits
de réponse immunitaire alors il ya deux
éléments maintenant qui conforte cette
hypothèse le premier c'est les résultats
des études en population de la
vaccination de troisième dose d
israéliens qui a bien réussi à faire
stopper la vague massive qu'ils ont eus
notamment grâce à cette troisième dose 1
pour vous donner un exemple quelqu'un
qui vacciner 3 12 contre de doses en
sachant qu'ils ont été vaccinées
extrêmement tôt en israël on diminue le
risque de contamination de 10 et de
formes graves de vins bon c'est des
chiffres faibles autant dans l'absolu
mais ça reste des rapports importants et
le deuxième point c'est que la variation
qu'on voit à la hausse jeudi une
variation alors moi je dis pas une
reprise de l'épidémie il ya une petite
fluctuation reste quand même la plupart
du temps en france sous le seuil
épidémique
elle touche beaucoup les 60 80 c'est
très bien pu la scion qui a signé le
plus tôt et dont on pense aujourd'hui
que le système immunitaire et la réponse
immunitaire a tendance à ses cuisines
donc de bonnes raisons pour lutter un
peu objectif pour relancer forcé cette
troisième dose dans la population oui on
est à deux millions de personnes
vaccinées sur les six millions de
personnes éligibles pour cette troisième
dose de vaccin et puis si on fait un
focus encore un peu plus
resserrée si on regarde parmi les les
résidents des ehpad on est à 46 % des
résidents des ehpad qui ont déjà reçu la
troisième dose de vaccin cette troisième
dos aux siens et ce qu'elle doit devenir
obligatoire pour que le pass sanitaires
restent valables voilà la question que
je vous pose et aux uns et aux autres
mais d'abord je vous propose d'entendre
ce que la ministre du travail elisabeth
bornes en 10 était sur europe 1 le
message c'est surtout que quand vous
êtes vous êtes effectivement une
personne âgée vulnérable que vous avez
été vaccinées il ya maintenant plus de
six mois c'est vraiment très important
on sait que l'immunité baisse fortement
au bout de six mois et donc il faut
absolument faire cette troisième du nom
pourrait perdre son pass à l'hiver
quelque chose qu'on regarde en tout cas
ça n'est pas décidée aujourd'hui voilà
la décision n'est pas prise on le
regarde ses fans le rudulier ce serait
cohérent d'une certaine façon on vous
tous vous pensez que là encore il ya un
voilà il ya peut-être une un nouveau
risque pour les libertés publiques de
voilà de conditionner le pass and i ter
à la troisième dose donc sur sur la
notion de troisième dose effectivement
et de là aussi aidé un accompagnement
beaucoup de pédagogie à faire notamment
sur les personnes les plus vulnérables
de là à partir sur le débat de la
vaccination obligatoire on l'avait déjà
eu au mois de juillet
fondamentalement il ya une impossibilité
matérielle de la contrainte elle veut
dire c'est bien beau de proclamer
vaccination obligatoire mais après
comment on contrôle moi je pose la
question est ce qu'on va aller contrôler
les 67 millions de français savoir s'ils
sont bel et bien vaccinés en présentant
le carnet de santé avec le certificat
médical donc là sanitaire c'est pas la
vaccination obligatoire non mais on
parlait de la vaccination obligatoire
tout à l'heure je jouais nommé là je dis
on je répète on s'est tous bien
conscients est-ce qu'il faut la
troisième dose pour que le pass annie
terre reste valable
si une baisse de l'immunité de la
personne forcément à fortiori je pense
qu'il faut la troisième dance pour faire
perdurer le sont parce sanitaire faut
être dans la même logique et y compris
on n'a pas encore eu les débats mais
peut-être que le professeur nous dire
pour l'instant on parle des personnes
âgées mais qu'en est il de la population
fut contre 40 et 60 ans entre 20 et 40
est ce qu'on a la même durée d'imiter
toutes ces questions là restent en
suspens c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi
au delà et là je reviens sur l'état
d'urgence
c'est une chose mais après c'est la
gestion de sortie de crise et comment on
sort de la crise et comment on anticipe
les futures épidémies et je pense que ça
c'est un débat qu'on doit avoir au delà
de l'état d'urgence parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on vote des textes
toujours entre guillemets en urgence
pour répondre à une situation épidémique
sans pour autant avoir de l'anticipation
sur la gestion de la sortie de crise et
la gestion des épidémies des futures
épidémies parce qu'on sait très bien
malheureusement que ce cas là peut se
reproduire dans les décennies qui arrive
sandra matin
je répète ma question je parfois un peu
tu es tu es quand est ce qu'on lit la
troisième dose opa sanitaire moi je
trouve que ce serait cohérent
a priori l'instant la décision n'est pas
prise on voit dans ce gouvernement est
un peu sur des oeufs et il ya une raison
pardon mais il ya une raison c'est sans
doute l'opinion publique il ya un
sondage doxa qui est
sorti à vos radios patiani 62% des
français favorables aux pass sanitaire
mais 58% pas d'accord pour qu'on dit
pour conditionner le pas salutaire à la
fameuse troisième dose donc ça fait
peut-être hésiter le gouvernement je
suis pas sûr qu'on prenne des décisions
sur la base de sondages heureusement
elles vont à peu près sûr qu'on fait
prenez en plein en plein procès
ça aurait donc changé
sinon je vous assure qu'on a rien pu
faire parce que si on regarde bien les
français étaient hostiles à la
vaccination il était hostile opa
sentheim finalement ils y sont venus et
ils l'ont adopté donc concrètement nous
gouverne pas avec des sondages par
contre là clairement moi je crois qu'il
ya une chose qui a changé qui est
important c'est que on attendait m'a
passé d'une d'une politique de
vaccination qui était fait dans des
centres sur lesquels les territoires ont
eu à et donc les collectivités locales
ont eu un rôle très important parce que
ils ont accueilli ces centres de
vaccination donc les gens ont pu y aller
assez très facilement on a été les
chercher et là on est dans une autre
logique celle de la les verts et donc ce
sont plutôt les pharmaciens les médecins
généralistes des gens en fait qu'ils
sont déjà au contact de ces personnes
très régulièrement qui sont chargés
d'aller les chercher finalement et de et
d'aller vers elle pour les vacciner donc
je crois que si on est dans une démarche
un peu différente plus basée sur la
confiance donc je pense que c'est plutôt
ça qui fait hésiter aujourd'hui le
gouvernement parce que c'est finalement
pas forcément les grands centres de
vaccination qui vont les prendre en
charge c'est plutôt les professionnels
libéraux qui ont l'habitude qui ont pas
forcément besoin de contraintes pour
pour réussir à convaincre ces personnes
qui ont déjà reçu deux doses donc là
c'est un troisième rappel en fait ni
plus ni moins donc c'est déjà des gens
qui finalement ont été convaincus et qui
se sont déjà fait vacciner deux fois
pour la plupart donc moi je pense
vraiment que on peut se donner un peu de
temps pour pour voir comment ça évolue
continuer à passer les messages et je
suis assez optimiste sur le fait que ne
soient pas forcés d'être dans une
contrainte ont en tout cas de mettre ce
pass sanitaires tant qu' il n'y aura pas
une majorité de français éligibles qui
seront vaccinés on va passer à la
question du secret médical mais des
élèves mais paul cassia juré que vous
réagissiez à ce que ses fans le haut et
juste avant est ce que finalement il
faut pas qu'on réfléchisse à une
adaptation
de notre droit peut-être de notre
constitution je sais pas jusqu'où aller
pour anticiper sur d'autres épidémies
mais je crois pas que les ans les
épidémies se règle par le droit et par
la modification de la constitution je
crois même qu'elle ne se règlent en
aucune manière par le droit et par la
modification de la constitution
je crois qu'elle doive s'anticiper c'est
pas mon boulot c'est celui du
gouvernement je suis pas en capacité de
réagir sur ce point sous le contrôle du
parlement donc les crises elles doivent
être anticipés et il faut des politiques
qui préviennent la survenance de crises
et et on sait qu'il va y avoir des
crises de toutes natures et la loi n'est
pas faite pour comme vient de le dire le
sénateur réagir en permanence à ce qui
pourrait arriver si les plus de 65 ans
je ne ressens pas on en est à la 11e ah
oui c'est ce que disait madame la
députée effet qu'un c'est la 11e fois
que le parlement se prononce ou est elle
appelée à se prononcer sur le kobe 19
c'est sans fin en réalité est ce que
vous disiez il ya un instant sur le
statut vaccinal des plus de 65 ans
appelle à un pass sanitaire forever en
réalité parce que bon après il faudra la
quatrième dose puisque après l'été sauf
erreur il ya l'automne puis l'hiver
prochain donc pour vérifier le statut
vaccinal il faudra un pass sanitaire de
ces questions là de même que la question
du terrorisme ne se règle pas par le
droit et pas par une modification de la
constitution très c'est au politique a
changé la main pour rebondir par rapport
à ça
on a des rappels par rapport à la grippe
et pour autant on n'était pas dans
l'état d'urgence sanitaire donc je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut sortir de
ce régime dérogatoire encore une fois et
après à l'être dans la coutume les le
pardon nous intéresse le secret médical
des élèves et on va entendre le ministre
de la santé c'était la nuit dernière à
l'assemblée il défend des sept
amendements du gouvernement un
amendement déposé par le gouvernement
sur la levée du secret médical pour les
élèves olivier ferrand vous le savez
probablement il ya des protocoles qui
sont en cours dans les écoles dans
plusieurs départements visant à éviter
de devoir fermer des classes lorsqu'il
ya un cas positif aujourd'hui tout cela
repose sur de l'auto déclaration de la
part des élèves ou des parents d'élèves
auprès du corps enseignant ce qui rend
le dispositif fragile et qui ne permet
pas d'envisager une généralisation dans
d'autres dans des bonnes conditions
aussi vous est proposé de permettre aux
directeurs d'établissement de faire une
saisine de l'assurance maladie sur la
base des élèves qui sont concernés pour
que la par l'intermédiaire de
l'assurance maladie il puisse connaître
le statut vaccinal des élèves et ainsi
pouvoir appliquer ces protocoles éviter
les fermetures des classes stéphane le
rugby est ce que ça fait partie des
parties du texte de cet amendement sur
lequel vous comptez revenir dans une
semaine au sénat en tout cas je pense qu
un débat très très dense sur ce sujet
parce que là encore c'est encore une
fois
un régime d'exception une contrainte
supplémentaire ce n'est pas le rôle et
là je rejoins patrick kanner du chef
d'établissement de contrôler la
situation de chaque chaque élève et
encore c'est une question de proportion
si on se disait bien clairement il y en
a pour un mois ou deux mois et après on
lève toutes ces
contraintes peut-être que ça serait
acceptable d'un point de vue la
population mais si au cumul je prend
huit mois de mesures d'exception je vais
jusqu'à la fin de l'année scolaire pour
avoir ces mesures qui perdure dans le
temps on ça on en fait on est en train
de s'habituer un régime d'exception où
on restreint au fur et à mesure nos
libertés c'est là où il y aura un point
d'achoppement à ce que si au fur et à
mesure on nous en rajoute excusez moi
l'expression il va y avoir une
contraction
du débat est forcément la qualité
derrière de la loi va s'en sortir sans
var matin alors concrètement je voudrais
d'abord rappeler les objectifs qu'on
poursuit avec ça on en a deux celui
qu'on a entendu que donnait le ministre
olivier ferrand c'est faire en sorte que
quand il ya un cas qui est qui révélait
dans une classe on puisse rapidement
mettre en place finalement le ce qu'on a
appelé c'est très moche mais le distant
ciel pour ceux qui sont les plus
fragiles qui ne sont pas protégés et
puis garder à l'école et ça c'est notre
objectif depuis le début de cette crise
garder à l'école les enfants qu'on peut
garder à l'école donc aujourd'hui on
fait confiance aux parents faut pas se
méprendre sur ce qui a été dit ni sur
l'intention on fait confiance aux
parents simplement on a un vrai souci
c'est que ça prend du temps ça prend du
temps de demander effectivement ces
déclarations à chaque fois puis à des
parents dont les enfants sont vaccinés a
qui ont deux efficaces ou liberté c
c'est une raison il ya effectivement une
notion d'efficacité pour aller vite pour
pouvoir mettre en place des
enseignements qui vont bien pour nos
enfants et c'est très important et puis
un deuxième objectif on a beaucoup
entendu à la rentrée les profs se plaint
que on n'avait pas assez testé qu'eux on
avez qu'on n'était pas prêts pour les
campagnes de vaccination bat pour
pouvoir bien cibler les campagnes de
tests pour pouvoir bien cibler ses
campagnes aussi de vaccination en a
besoin d'information aujourd'hui on peut
pas le faire on les a pas on ne sait pas
effectivement la proportion des jeunes
qui sont pas vaccinés donc on ne peut
pas ciblé aujourd'hui les établissements
dans lesquels on aurait besoin de mettre
le paquet c'est aussi l'objectif
notamment au travers des tests et des
campagnes de tests très court avant que
vous preniez la parole parce que je suis
sûr vous allez réagir je rappelle quand
même que pour inscrire son enfant à
l'école primaire il est obligatoire de
présenter tous les médecins ou les sont
obligatoires dans en école primaire donc
là il s'agit juste déplacer cette
contrainte sur le secondaire bon
pourquoi on l'acceptera en primaire pour
11 500
mons vaccin est pas un à partir de la
sixième fois voyez en fait il ya tout ça
aussi dans l'acceptabilité de la
population parce que vous avez raison
c'est évidemment le noeud le de soulever
cette politique pour l'instant le vaccin
contre la copie n'est pas obligatoire
donc il fait pas il n'est pas le 12e bac
5 c'est un peu la particularité alors
juste le mot sur la méthode le projet de
loi a été présenté au parlement le 13
octobre et sur le siège tout d'un coup
hier en tout cas moi c'est comme ça que
j'ai découvert ministre on avait parlé
en commission il l'avait dit dans son
propos introductif et l'a rappelé hier
soir au bon d'ailleurs à très bien bon
alors moi j'ai découvert cette cet
amendement cet amendement hier bon en
tout cas il n'a pas passé le filtre du
conseil d'état et s'agissant de l'étude
d'impact on ne sait rien de ce que
pourrait produire ce type de deux
propositions donc tu es sur le plan de
la méthode déjà je suis un petit peu
dubitatif et je n'ai pas d'opinion
véritable sur le sujet sauf que là
encore on porte atteinte au secret
médical 2 on poursuit la logique du pass
à lithaire qui est de faire de chacun de
nous le contrôleur de l'autre est ici en
l'occurrence comme ça vient d'être dit
par monsieur le sénateur du chef
d'établissement le contrôleur du statut
vaccinal des élèves je veux qu'on soit
très clair ou ensor absolument pas de
passer ni tard à l'école voudrais pas
que des gens se méprennent wii ne
s'instaure absolument pas ce que j'ai en
face entre cole c'est extrêmement
important bien sûr c'est parce que
j'étais à l'aise non non pas du tout pas
du tout africain l'autre le palais c'est
que le pass sanitaire est contrôlé par
des personnes privées vis-à-vis d'autres
personnes privées et ici on donne or au
chef d'établissement le rôle de enfin
finalement le même rôle que pour les
personnes qui contrôlent nos passes
annie terre il est le contrôleur
permanent de la santé vaccinale du
statut vaccinal de ces vélos cède une
information effectivement oui on
commence vers rue d'information est
d'ailleurs csl et dernièrement dans le
temps c'est limité dans le temps soyons
pour un objectif très précis aussi donc
le voilà c'est pas non plus commenté
pourquoi honnêtement on a des chefs
d'établissement qui connaissent beaucoup
de choses déjà heureusement sur les
enfants qu'ils accueillent tous les
jours dans leur établissement et qui ont
des fois au delà de ce qu'on pourrait
avoir on verra si
cette entaille dans le secret médical
passe ou non au crible du sénat merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau merci à philippe amouyel qui
était évidemment également avec nous en
visioconférence on passe à notre
rubrique les électeurs ont la parole